What we've been doing here are the first steps of
what is called low fidelity prototyping. This is where we
take paper to make simple representations of our designs. We
create paper prototypes for communication, and to demonstrate our ideas.
And to find out what works for a user. We
don't want to invest too much into it, sketching is
cheap and engineering is expensive. You said the word wire-frames.
Can you I've heard that word a lot. Can you explain
what that is?
>> Well, actually Clifton has a great example of a wire-frame.
A wire-frame shows the basic information and placement of different elements.
So he's got a little token here that kind of represents an
image. You know, and I think that's become so familiar to
us that we know that that's like a picture of somebody,
even though it doesn't look like anybody I know. In fact,
it looks kind of like a question mark with a little hump.
And then this is text, placement for text. And he's out
it within this frame, which is actually very similar to this frame.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Right? Of our device. So and then he's got some
call outs and labels. So this, essentially, is wire frames, all
these are wire frames. And the difference, say, between his wire
frames and yours is that he's constrained them by a frame.
>> Oh.
>> [COUGH] He's sort of put that around and he's thought a little bit about
how things are positioned within this constraint. So,
he's already one step ahead, which is fine.
>> Wire frames show placement in an actual frame
of a device. And flows are sequences of wire
frames. Flows work to create a user interface story,
in much the same way as a comic strip tells
a story. Now, let's actually make some wire frames
and flows, using those conceptual models that we made earlier.
In fact, let's bring all the elements you generated
before, including the conceptual models, the discoverable signifiers, and the
feedback, into our wire frames and story board.